and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Scott Pilgrim vs. the
well the who is that I mean there's
drugs and then there's this I mean a man
this was friggin weird oh by the way yes
boy loses great movie ever seen a
midnight maybe weird
uses boy who's played by that boy who's
gonna play a boy for the rest of his
life and he falls in love with a girl
named knives I am guessing they coded it
because it was a heartburn and she's
like save a hot girlfriend who's totally
crazy about me life is hell but then he
meets another girl whose hair keeps
changing color like a new bling and he's
like oh my god this chicks a total bitch
is she wants nothing to do with me I
want her okay this is weird
maybe this is how he sees the world but
it's like no they all live in the world
of sound effects and anime and video
game references oh well maybe it's not a
dream methedrine dreams are sensical
compared to this so then I'm like maybe
they're all blissed on drugs trust me I
would know what that looks like this is
just sort of the world it doesn't make
sense but hot chicks are in it so it's
rise to any means the boy is like oh the
point seven evil exes for you okay
you're so bitchy and hate everything the
world so much
you're totally worthless butl to
Macaulay Culkin's brother isn't it a
nice day
it's about it so the boy fights all the
seven evil exes one's a teen stars
one's a movie star was a vegan and one's
a really hot southern shake
like please short flashback please show
flashback finally he gets to the major
bad act so he's like I put a microchip
in your girlfriend so now you only obey
me
yes so nice comes in to fight alongside
the boy you fight so the boy defeats the
number one even act knives saves his
life about a bajillion times and she's
like we make a good team you know
it's a twilight complex I had to go out
with the person who stabbed so it works
for me and that will be me why do I even
bother
homo the end so as you can see this
movie was weird go to an anime con just
imagine a whole movie like that it's
like if you got a person drunk gave him
a bunch of drugs spun him around and
then send them off to an anime con this
is what you would see and by god that
does not sound like a minute.you to the
liquor store
all that's missing is a bunch of bright
flashes to give you a seizure
this is just insane
charge these give me some money now that
boy grow up
he's been halfway through puberty 20
years now